and it's super nice to have you in the
podcast studio thanks for making the
trip out excited to talk to you it's
beautiful out here
yeah it's my honor thanks good well
there's so much to unpack here but first
before we even get into it I wanted to
hear a little bit about you being
honored by the LA City Council the other
day yeah it was quite an honor I have
been at a lot of government buildings
usually outside protesting things yeah
or um you know fighting charges for
being arrested for fighting on behalf of
animals so to be honored by the city of
Los Angeles for my nearly two decades of
work was pretty phenomenal and they said
some really nice things about me and the
organization in LA has led the way and
and in many regards for animal
protection issues the the same City
Council that gave me this award voted
unanimously to ban bullhooks
you know these weapons that are used
against elephants and circuses that
really was the beginning of the end for
circuses in Los Angeles and the US
across the u.s. so yeah it's nice to be
recognized that's cool and like Eric
Garcetti was there and everything he was
yeah a photo-op I got the photo-op with
the Mary yeah yes it all come full it's
amazing well let's go let's go back to
the beginning I mean this you know your
your life as an animal rights activist
is not something that you know it's not
a bandwagon that you jumped on because
it was vogue I mean this is like born
and bred and you know heavily wound into
your DNA from almost day one for you I
mean it's crazy how far back this goes
with you I think it very well could be
in my my DNA I I talk in the book about
the fact that I was delivered by a
veterinarian
my dad Marc graduated vet school from
OSU and met my mom at
horseback riding camp that my dad used
to run so both of my parents were very
hands-on with animals and for me I know
why my friend is he's not evil act very
curious about what's happening here but
for me you know being born on a farm in
rural Ohio a village of less than 2,000
people I was surrounded by animals from
my earliest childhood memory and I
always draw on to them I always loved
animals I could always sort of put
myself in their place and imagine even
for a moment what life must be like for
them and that instilled a great level of
empathy within me for for all animals so
that was that was sort of the the basis
and then this flyer really is quite
interested work it out yeah I mean I
think you you just came out of the womb
very sensitive to that almost like it's
a past life thing like you know there
was never any question about what your
life was gonna be about it's true it's
true and you know reflecting back on on
starting the organization when I was 15
and becoming a vet Sharon was 11 it all
just sort of seems like it was always
meant to be and people will say oh my
gosh that was so young that's so amazing
for me it never felt like that it just
always felt like a natural calling I was
always being pulled in that direction it
was it wasn't really a choice it was the
only option right the calling and
calling your parents particularly your
mom was super supportive I mean it seems
like from the book you know she was your
champion from day one yeah and I was
fortunate enough to have two parents who
I think they're sort of philosophy on
raising children my sister and I was
it's your life make your decisions and
we'll be here to support you
and being a vegan or becoming vegan
starting in a more it's organization I
think was something that my mother at
least initially was was very proud of I
think it took my dad a while to sort of
come around and and fully understand the
scope of the work and why it was so
meaningful but yeah a lot of pride from
the family so you grow up on this farm
in rural Ohio coming from a long line of
Ohio farmers that gave back you know
generation after generation so you grow
up with all these animals and you're the
kid who's you know bringing home every
wounded animal that you can find and we
have Cesar the the rat who becomes your
best friend and yeah and so you're that
guy right yeah from the beginning from
the beginning and and and around
livestock animals from a very early age
too but it was a very different time in
terms of how those animals were raised
and treated that's right so I would
rescue you know birds that would fall
out of trees I'd find you know feral
cats in the barn and we'd get them
adopted there were just always animals
around that I was sort of nurturing and
taking care of and Cesar the rat that
you mentioned was this rat that I
rescued from our neighbors who bred
animals to be used in laboratory
experiments and he came home with me
when I was six years old and he would
sit on my shoulder and just became my
best friend and it was Cesar who really
taught me that all animals have
personalities and minds they feel
loneliness and joy and they have sense
of curiosity and they crave freedom it's
not just dogs and cats and I would I
would have friends come over and I would
be so excited for them to meet Cesar
because he was so important to me yeah
but most of them would be really sort of
terrified of him and they would shriek
in horror at the sight of his tail like
people couldn't get over this site of a
rat's tail and so at this young age I
started to see that we
bring a lot of prejudice to the table
with animals and we arbitrarily call
some pests and others pets and so Cesar
challenge that notion for me of why we
extend our consideration for some
animals but not others yes specie ISM is
a very bizarre weird
yes psychological phenomenon you know
and as somebody who was raised around
pigs and cows and these animals had
names it was not unusual for you to
observe the bond that transpired between
human and animal but that didn't extend
to the rat right so it's kind of your
first exposure to that idea and that
differentiation that we kind of
psychologically and mentally yeah which
is which is weird but the thing you know
this whole kind of path that you're on
seems to have crystallized around this
one event that takes place around a
dissection that's right and like walk us
through that story yeah so I was 15
years old
and again farming community 2,000 people
at the high school there's an
agriculture class and the teacher of the
class is a pig farmer his name's mr.
Jenkins and he raises out 11 thousand
pigs so he has a very large scale
operation that he's running now one may
morning in 1999 mr. Jenkins decided that
they're going to do a dissection project
and he's going to kill some baby piglets
on his farm to use now he arrives to the
school with this bucket filled with baby
piglets that are supposed to be dead he
goes into the classroom he sits the
bucket down and a student walks over and
notices that one of the piglets is still
alive in fact she's standing on top of
the others in this bucket so the teacher
instructs the the student to do
something about it he he grabs the
piglet by her hind legs and slams her
headfirst into the ground
now this is a senior in the class who
did part-time work on mr. Jenkins pig
farm now this piglet still didn't die
her skull was now fracture
she was bleeding out of the mouth she
was just horrible distress so a few of
the students were just sickened by what
they had seen they took this baby piglet
and they left the classroom they went
down the hall to another teacher's room
her name is Molly fearing and she was a
first-year teacher at the school she was
known as being the vegetarian who cares
about animals hmm so Molly with this
baby piglet cradled in her arms left the
school and went to a local veterinarian
about ten minutes away and had the
piglet euthanized
Molly's next step was to the sheriff's
department where she said look this
piglet was just killed in this horrible
way there should be animal cruelty
charges filed and eventually charges
were filed against mr. Jenkins not not
the student himself it went to court and
it was a big deal in this agriculture
community as you could imagine it
becomes this big news story that like
kind of polarizes yeah town right so
it's uh it's in the paper
I mean local TV stations are doing
stories about it there are letters to
editor of the local papers it's just you
know the tensions are rising and the
first day of that trial the benches are
packed at that court with pig farmers
that show up to rally behind mr. Jenkins
they don't want animal advocates telling
them what to do they don't want you know
the site type of criticism for their
practices in the the very first day of
that trial those charges were dismissed
and the reason that they were dismissed
is because in Ohio like at least 30
other states if something is considered
quote standard agricultural practice
it's exempt from cruelty prosecution and
this practice of slamming piglets into
the ground headfirst is standard
practice it's deemed legal and we still
find it all across the country when we
go into factory farms so that that case
Illustrated to me that there needed to
be an organization that would give a
voice to to farm to animals and it was
really clear to me that if this had been
a
P or kitten the outcome would have been
very different of that it wouldn't have
been tolerated they there would have
probably been perhaps jail time
certainly psychiatric evaluation would
have been suggested probably a
prohibition of owning animals but
because it was a piglet it was just
deemed common business standard
practices right like if if a teenager or
a preteen did that to a dog they right
they would say this is the you know this
is you know this kids this kid's a
potential serial killer right you know I
mean like we should pay attention to
what this kid is doing and it's
interesting the differentiation and in
the treatment and the way we think about
these things and also the lack of you
know defined terms when it comes to
standard agricultural practices right
like what does that mean it cast this
broad net and so much can fall
underneath that and that's still you
know a battle that I know you know you
and and and MFA are waging it's it's
true because what it does is it hands
over the authority to decide what is
acceptable and what is legal to the very
industries and individuals that profit
off of these animals and so they're
always going to to do what's the
cheapest and the fastest not what is in
the best interest of the animals so to
me it's similar to handing over
authority to chemical companies to
decide what's an appropriate amount of
toxic chemicals to put into the
groundwater or you know into the air
like most people would consider that to
be ridiculous for us to be some sort of
regulation or oversight but for sorry
animals that's what's happening right
yeah totally so yeah else you're how old
at this point 15 to 15 yeah okay yeah I
can't even drive yet and no Facebook or
social media yeah none of that song
although it was soon to come that's
right I'm sure you're young but it's
interesting that not only are you kind
of carrying this frequency of already
you know pursuing this path and being
interested in this world this huge thing
happens that you find yourself right in
the in the middle of it's like this you
know
perfect storm of events from which to
birth you no mercy for animals which you
created at age 15 which I did not know I
mean that's you know at 15 you create
this organization now that you are what
you have a hundred and thirty employees
and like sixty countries or something
how many six countries big ones yeah I
mean this was this was created when you
were fifteen years old it's unbelievable
yeah it's it is it is a little bit
unbelievable it's been it's been my
life's work it's been 18 years now since
since starting the organization but it
has been the most fulfilling work the
most meaningful work challenging work
but you know I the organization and
obviously there are so many people that
are part of the organization I'm you
know one person sort of holding space
and and doing what I can for it it's
it's it's the organization is made up of
you know thousands of volunteers
thousands of people that donate money
undercover investigators like it's it's
a it's a wide network of really
incredible individuals but the progress
that we've helped push forward is is
really shifting the game for farm to
animals yeah there's no question about
it so you know we'll get back to the
timeline yet I think it would be
worthwhile to kind of explain the
mission statement of Mercy for Animals
and also to try to contextualize the
role of MFA in comparison to the other
organizations out there like PETA and
compassion over killing and yeah Humane
Society you know and the like so the the
mission of Mercy for Animals is to
prevent cruelty to farmed animals and
promote compassionate food choices and
policies so we do that through four
program areas one is undercover
investigations and this is one of the
things that we're most known for sending
people into factory farms
slaughterhouses livestock auctions
hatcheries wired with hidden cameras and
then working sometimes for months on end
and documenting how these animals are
crammed in cages where they can't turn
around mutilate without painkillers
separated from their fan
have their throats slit well they're
conscious in slaughterhouses and using
that evidence to then support our other
program areas the second being legal
advocacy so one enforcing the very very
few bare bones state laws that are on
the books to protect farmed animals but
more importantly pushing for stronger
laws you know as I said we have these
common farming exemptions that mean that
you can essentially do anything to farm
animals as long as a lot of people are
doing it things that would be illegal if
they were dogs or cats and we have most
of the animals kept in confined systems
where they you know can't engage in
natural behaviors they have no access to
the outdoors so pushing for more legal
protection for these animals the fourth
or the third area is corporate outreach
so getting big companies like Walmart
and McDonald's to and the worst forms of
abuse that animals endure on on factory
farms adhering to the internationally
accepted five freedoms that like freedom
from hunger and thirst pain pain and
discomfort freedom for natural movement
those types of things but in practice
that meaning an end to battery cages for
egg-laying hens or five six seven birds
are kept in cages the size of a file
cabinet drawer can't spread their wings
can't walk can't purchase dust-bathing
natural ending the confinement of mother
Sal's and gestation crates where they
can't turn around and and confinement of
baby calves and veal crates ending the
mutilation of animals so no tail docking
no castration without pain relief and
changing the genetics of these animals
you know these animals are now really
Frankenstein animals they've been bred
to grow so large and so fast they can't
even walk naturally oftentimes and
ending the the really horrific slaughter
of chickens which have no federal
protection at slaughter there's not a
single federal law for any farmed
animals during their lives in the farm
right like you're just I don't want you
to just gloss over that fact yes that's
really kind of amazing and illustrative
of
where we are I mean there's there's a
bunch of state laws and those state laws
vary of course but no there's no federal
legislation on how we regulate how these
animals are treated which is it just
seems weird and bizarre it is minoo
federal regulation for how farmed
animals are treated on the farm there
are two two laws one regarding
transportation which is the last you
know day or so of the animals lives and
and that that law is just so poorly
enforced and almost meaningless right
menu 28 they can't be in a truck for
longer than 28 hours or something like
that that's right
that's right and and then there's the
humane methods of slaughter Act which
completely exempts 98% of the animals
that are killed for food land animals
almost all because it doesn't include
fish either so that that basic law says
that these animals are supposed to be
rendered unconscious before their
throats are slit but for for birds
the typical way in which they're killed
is they're dumped out of crates onto
these moving conveyor belts workers snap
them into shackles by their fragile legs
many of them have broken bones and been
bruising and then they go through an
electrified vat of water which paralyzes
the birds and then they have their
throat slit by spinning blade and a lot
of these these birds are still alive
when they go into scalding tanks of
water the USDA on their own estimates
which are entirely you know too low say
that at least a million animals a year
are scalded alive at the slaughterhouse
and then the fourth program area is
education work so this is really focused
on informing informing people about
where their food comes from and who
they're eating and the fact that that
farmed animals again they have rich
emotional lives they're intelligent they
they matter they're their lives matter
the treatment of them matters and that
we can we can make compassionate food
choices when we sit down to eat so a lot
of our education work is based on
promoting a plant-based diet encouraging
people to crowd meat off of the plate
and and and really
eat plants as a way of sparing animals
from the suffering that that we're
talking about right and why did you
decide to focus exclusively on farmed
animals well they are the 99%
you know we we talked so much about
companion animals and dogs and cats the
half of us share our homes with them
half of those animals will receive
Christmas gifts this holiday season you
know we spend billions of dollars on
their care and elective surgeries we
live in it in a world and in a country
of people who love animals but really
when people say that they're mostly
talking about dogs and cats because
those are who we know as individuals and
those are who are most present in our
lives we come home to them but when
we're really talking about animals we're
talking about farmed animals 3,000 times
as many farmed animals are killed in the
United States then dogs and cats are
euthanized in shelters three thousand to
one you know we're talking about over
nine billion of them every single year
in the u.s. that's almost 300 every
second so why farm animals because
because all of these animals matter and
we only have so much time and resources
and energy so we should direct it to
where there's the most suffering and
where we have the opportunity to do the
most good when you look at factory
farming and the number of farmed animals
I mean the statistics really are
staggering I mean 9 billion in the US
alone and that doesn't include fish
right so it could be you know because
they do that by weight and now I
individual and globally you had
estimated somewhere between 50 to 100
billion land animals alone right it's
insane right it's insane so what one of
the things I thought was really
interesting about your book is you kind
of give this primer this history of how
of how factory farming evolved like
nobody is super enthusiastic about
factory farming but this is the world in
which we live and this is how we've you
know created a way to feed the planet
but I think it would be instructive to
kind of take a step back and look at how
we got here as a way of contextualizing
how
perhaps we can solve this problem and
create better ways that flies back the
fly is back or the Vengeance well you
know I I think like a lot of things
throughout history
our ancestors were trying to do the best
that they could with what they had under
the current circumstances so or under
the circumstances that they were were
living in so I'm not I'm not here to you
know condemn those that came before me I
think they they were doing what they
thought was necessary but certainly in
this day and age with a global
population racing towards almost 10
billion by 2050 and the the threats of
climate change and in all of the
knowledge that we have it's clear that
the old way of doing things just isn't
going to be sustainable for us not to
mention it's just completely cruel and
inhumane and to the animals that are
victims of it but you know we people
didn't always eat this much meat you
know this is a relatively new phenomenon
throughout human history and you know
factory farming as we know it is
something that my my great-grandfather
was in the middle of when he was right
he he he raised pigs the way that a lot
of people still think pigs are raised
out you know out in the field and I talk
about it in my book how it was it was in
that time in the early you know 1900s
when these factory confinement systems
started to come about in the u.s. at
these things like gestation crates and
like Ferren crates in my my
great-grandfather said I'm not going to
use them because they're too hard on the
south but you know beginning of World
War one there was a push to need to
produce a lot of food and a lot of
protein and and there was this push to
produce a lot of chicken especially
specifically and in and with that at the
same time you know around the the 40s or
so we started seeing places like
McDonald
in KFC you know rise and so you can look
at a chart of meat consumption in the
United States and you can see you know
just this incredible spike in meat
consumption and the the slaughter of
chickens
mostly chickens you know starting back
in the 60s or 70s or so is just this
dramatic incline so you know it was
taking these these factory models and
taking animals from the outdoors putting
them inside giving animals vitamin D and
things so that they didn't need as much
sunlight manipulating their diet
manipulating their like lighting cycles
and then of course we had penicillin and
antibiotics so we were able to keep
animals and conditions that otherwise
they wouldn't naturally live in because
they're they're too filthy and it's too
stressful and now we you know start
feeding animals these routine you know
non-therapeutic antibiotics and of
course we all know the problems with
that now as well with you know superbugs
and but some say at least 70% of
antibiotics now being fed directly to
farm animals so it's just a total mess
it's a it's a system that's out of
control and it's not sustainable on
every measurable level that we look at
so again I I in part of writing that the
book was a lot of reflection about the
history of how we got here but I I think
that we have an opportunity to be really
intentional about what the future of
food looks like and I talked about that
in the book too right and we're gonna
get to that yes the pioneering clean
meat yep Matt which is super fascinating
and as you probably know I had Bruce
Friedrich on oh good to talk about that
in the past so yeah and I love talking
about that stuff but in in the context
of a factory farming give us a lay of
the land of what we're currently kind of
looking at in terms of how the typical
cow and chicken are treated yeah so
there are really two main breeds of
chicken
that are used and one is the egg-laying
chicken the white leghorn and they have
been bred to be rather small birds who
produce a lot of eggs so the the modern
chicken that's used for for food
production or eggs originated from
jungle fowl from Southeast Asia and in
nature these birds you know would lay
about two clutches of eggs a year so
about two dozen eggs the entire year
they'd spend much of their time you know
running around building nests exploring
looking for insects had a really rich
rich life would live to be over ten
years old we domesticated these birds
and started manipulating their genetics
so now for the egg-laying breeds they
lay over 200 eggs every year and this
takes a big toll on the birds bodies
because these eggs take up so much
calcium for the shell and what's in them
so a lot of these birds suffer from
osteoporosis and a lot of them suffer
from broken bones by the time they're
pulled out of their cages and are
slaughtered right and their legs can't
really sustain the weight right so they
can't even really walk so that's the
broiler chickens the type birds and
these are birds that have been bred
through genetic selection to be really
big because the characteristic that
they're being bred for is breast meat or
thigh meat because that's what the
companies want and in order for that to
happen there are of course unintended
consequences which are the birds can't
walk naturally studies show that about
90% of them are essentially lying down
in the last few days of their lives
because it's just so incredibly painful
for them to walk they have joint pain
and they suffer from heart problems lung
problems similar things that you would
see with really obese children the same
sort of joint pains and everything
you're seeing with these birds because
they are they are babies and if you
listen to them they're they're
essentially chirping as if they're their
babies because they are they're only 45
days old when they're slaughtered
the egg Liang Birds the male's super
broiler chickens both male and female
birds are bred and they're kept in these
huge windowless sheds packed in there by
the literally tens of thousands living
in their own excrement they suffer from
sores on their their legs on their
breasts blisters they really don't have
access to natural light so they're and
they do that intentionally so that the
birds will grow faster so they don't
even have a natural activity schedule
they grow faster without the light
because they don't want them moving
around as much because you know what
when there's energy that's right that's
right they just want them to to eat grow
and go to slaughter that is that is the
that is the business model for these
broiler operations they're they're then
taken to the slaughterhouse and are
killed in the way that that we discussed
earlier now on the the egg-laying side
it's only the females that are used the
males because they're not this breed
that grows really large and they don't
produce eggs they're useless so they are
killed right away and I tell the story
in the book about an investigation at
Highline hatchery which is one of the
largest hatcheries in the entire world
they hatch hundreds of thousands of
birds every single week and we
documented what happens to all of these
males and what happens is there are
these people called sexers and they
there are these conveyor belts with the
chicks on them and it gets to this area
where there are people that sit around
and their job all day is to grab chicks
by their wings look and see if they're
male or female and then toss them in one
of two directions one is where the
females go and the other is a chute and
they go down this chute and then the
conveyor belt takes them into this room
that most people can't get into and
what's in that room is a huge macerator
where the conveyor belt of the birds are
dropped into and then they're ground up
alive so the males are just ground up
right away they're ground up alive yeah
yeah that's how that's how they're
killed and it's just all day
there's just checks being dumped into
this macerator and and in some ways
they're the lucky ones because the fate
is so horrible for for the females so if
they go if they're female and they go
down the other chute
they will have their beaks burned off
either with a hot blade or with a laser
and then they'll be trucked off to a
facility where they'll be putting these
tiny cages that are stacked on top of
each other they'll never feel the grass
under their feet they'll never see
sunlight will never breathe fresh air
and they live in these cages for usually
about two years and then their egg
production starts to decline and they're
considered worn out and they're also
killed sometimes they're thrown into gas
carts
right there on the farm they're gas with
co2
sometimes they're sent and slaughtered
for low-grade products like chicken soup
or something and what happens to the
masticated chickens and the feces and
the waste like how is that managed well
it's similar to all factory farms at the
in pig farms and dairy farms are are
huge you know literal polluters in the
sense that the the waste of these
animals is not regulated in the same way
that human waste is and you know you you
have a situation where for example with
cows and pigs they produce you know more
waste one animal then perhaps a you know
multiple humans would be producing and
they'll go into these huge essentially
manure lagoons and they will sit there
collecting in a bacteria it's a huge
environmental hazard they try to spray
some of it on nearby fields right there
was that scene and what the health
that's right that happening that's right
and this happens all that all over the
place spraying they're literally
spraying them on fields like it looks
like it's fertilizer or they're
irrigating crops but it's just fecal
matter and yeast
yeah and a lot of these farms are in you
know communities of color
you know underprivileged communities so
there's it like there are so many issues
that are really embodied and what's
happening here comes a socio-economic
for all absolutely so and then and then
a you know it'll rain and our unused
waste will get into the nearby creeks
and streams and groundwater and I talk
in the book about an egg farm in Ohio
and at the time when I was the largest
egg producing state in the entire
country now it's still you know in the
top the top bracket but there was the
largest egg firm they're called Buckeye
egg farm and it was run by this man
named Dan Tom Pullman who was actually
banned from owning chickens in Germany
because of Cruelty to Animals but Ohio
and the u.s. said hey come on over we
want you to build your operation here so
you know sorry to interrupt you but you
go through kind of a laundry list of the
things that he did in Germany and it's
just it's unbelievable right yeah he
could just pack up and come over here
yeah and set up shop after what he had
what are you done there yeah and then he
did the exact same thing in the United
States so his environmental violations
fly infestations of local schools and
communities and people's property values
plummeting because nobody nobody wants
to buy a house surrounded by ten million
chickens and manure and flies and and
everything from child labor issues and
in violations at the farm it's just I
mean these are these are dark sad places
and every way that you can imagine so so
that's that's sort of the the aerial
view of what life is like for four hens
you mentioned what life is like for for
four cows you know the the worst
treatment is of in the dairy industry
actually and a lot of people don't
really think about animal cruelty in the
egg industry or in the dairy industry
because we think well you know an animal
doesn't directly need to die for that so
it must be okay as long as they're
living good lives but the the truth is
that oftentimes it's just prolonged
cruelty for these animals and they are
slaughtered
there's not you know a big sanctuary
where where millions and millions of
animals right there's no happy pasture
for these animals so in the dairy
industry you have again a situation
that's based off of the reproductive
manipulation of animals where the male's
also aren't useful so they're also
considered useless byproducts and that's
where the veal industry comes from dairy
cows used for dairy are just like any
other mammal you know what makes us
mammals well a number of things but one
is that we feed our young through milk
and cowls are the same they they only
produce milk to feed their babies not
you know because right not because of a
dairy company wants to you know make
profits off in them so they have to be
artificially impregnated then give birth
those babies obviously if they were
drinking the milk then there wouldn't be
any amount to be sold to people so the
babies are literally dragged away within
a few hours of being born right there's
all those videos that are
heart-wrenching yeah of the calves being
separated from the mother and the mother
whelping and yeah I know it's it's awful
to watch it is awful to watch and and
that is that plays itself out countless
times a day and the dairy industry those
videos aren't you know some exceptional
thing that's happened somebody just you
know filmed it but that is that is the
emotional heartbreak that these animals
suffer every single time that their
babies are taken from them in the dairy
industry and you know I think any any
mother could relate to what that must be
like on some level and I I tell a story
in the book about the sort of Sophie's
Choice situation a very small actually
family farm in New York where there was
this cow who had given birth
out and pasture and she had she'd been
used by the dairy farm for for a number
of years now so she knew what happened
when she gave birth she knew that her
baby was gonna be taken away from her
and they took they took the baby away
but she kept coming back from the field
to be milked without much milk to give
or to be taken really and they didn't
understand what was wrong because she
seemed like she was in good health
one day they followed her out into the
field and and realized that she in fact
had given birth to twins and that there
was another calf that was out in the
field that she was protecting because
she knew that they would take one of her
calves away she literally like hid her
baby yeah yeah and she made this
heartbreaking choice of giving up one of
them to save the other because she knew
from past experiences what was going to
happen right which shed the light on the
interior lives and its arrangements of
these animals oh absolutely and they
they remember they think about the past
they think about the future they plan
you know Jane Goodall she she once said
that we have to understand that we're
not the only beings on this planet with
personalities and minds and it's basic
but it's true
so so that's that that is that is the
beginning for these these animals in the
dairy industry the the females will then
be kept in in factory conditions where
some of them will be chained by their
necks others will just be confined
indoors about three four times a day
they'll be taken into a milking parlor
area and hooked up with electrical
sucking devices now a physical abuse to
these animals is really extreme and
inside of these environments because
you'll have people working inside of
these operations that are tasked with
moving hundreds thousands of animals a
day and a very short period of time in
really brutal conditions and so people
become descents
as to what's taking place there and
violence quickly follows they'll take
out their frustration and their anger on
the animals in front of them and we've
documented dairy farms workers using
pitchforks to stab cows breaking their
tails using crowbars to beat them over
the head just really the most
heartbreaking type of abuse that you
could imagine it's interesting that
phenomenon and it makes you wonder you
know did these employees come in with
that disposition or did the experience
of working there and you know having to
kind of repress you know their their own
gosh annette feelings lead to that kind
of behavior i you know this is something
that i really struggled with and i feel
like i have a much deeper understanding
of it because Mercy for Animals has done
over 60 undercover investigations and I
think that there's a small small number
of individuals that work at factory
farms that are sort of sadistic and
enjoy abusing animals and and use their
place of power there to fulfill this
really sort of sick desire to to torture
animals we see that every once in a
while but the norm is that you have an
under underprivileged vulnerable
community of people mostly undocumented
immigrants who take these jobs in
factory farms and slaughterhouses very
few people grow up wanting to work at a
slaughterhouse or in a factory farm
that's not what people aspire to so you
know this is this is the work that most
Americans will not take so we have
people that take these jobs which are
some of the most dangerous in the entire
country slaughterhouse is one of the
most dangerous jobs that you can get
high rates of amputation carpal tunnel
syndrome you know back injuries
everything physically dangerous then you
also have an emotionally traumatizing
I mean you can imagine it is someone's
job for eight hours a day to sit with a
knife and slit the throat of chickens
who missed the automated blade somebody
sits there with an iPad on and iPod you
know listening to music slitting the
throats of animals right and having to
sublimate that so yeah day in and day
out like there's just no way that that
is not taking a huge emotional attack on
a human being
exactly and so we see and and and
there's been studies done on this as
well but our investigators say all the
time really high rates of alcoholism and
drug abuse especially methamphetamines
inside of these operations so you have
people one really physically demanding
work and then two as you said there's
emotional trauma that they're suffering
and I talk in the book about
perpetration induced traumatic stress
which is a form of PTSD where you take
people who are put in positions of jobs
to carry out acts of violence that they
normally wouldn't do in good
consciousness and that's exactly what
the jobs are at slaughterhouses you have
people who come in take these jobs out
of desperation are filled with
compassion care about animals but within
a day or a few days imagine what a month
or a year would do you know these these
people have to numb themselves have to
disconnect have to not care about what
they're doing and what's taking place in
front of them and there was there's a
study that looked at the Sinclair effect
this theory that Upton Sinclair put
forward a hundred years ago when he
noticed that there were rates of violent
crime much higher around slaughterhouses
than in other areas and the the research
shows that that is in fact a phenomenon
and we have higher rates of violent
crime with homicides in some cases being
carried out in the same way that animals
are killed that people's throats being
slit in that manner in communities where
there are slaughterhouses so
animals are definitely the biggest
victim in terms of number and and and
it's and and and duration of suffering
but they're not the only victims of
these these industries and systems as
well and to me it's it's a it's a simple
question do slaughterhouses have a place
in a civilized moral ethical enlightened
conscious society to me the answer is no
right
yeah and Upton Sinclair what was it 1904
winning yeah book came out 1906 yeah he
no 6 yep and that book had a huge impact
it does still taught in schools and it
had you know it had a pronounced impact
on the administration of legislation at
the time it was kind of a sensation
right it was and yet the long-term
impact of that was unheated right
because here we are today and people
like yourself are putting out books on
the same subject and advocating in the
way that you do and yet it seems
although culture is shifting and we're
in a new era and that's very exciting
and I have a lot of optimism around that
you know there's still a lot that needs
to be heard that is not like it's not
landing right yeah and when we talk
about you know the oversight and the
regulation and we'll get a little bit
more into you know what that regulatory
landscape looks like it doesn't seem
like anything is really being handled
properly right where where is the
oversight where is you know where is the
USDA and all of this and why is there
not more hands-on governance in terms of
policing what is okay and what isn't at
least in the construct of accepting that
this is how we're feeding the planet at
current moment
well it comes down to money and power
and the agriculture industry and most
specifically the meat industry the dairy
industry are really powerful lobbyists
and they don't want oversight and they
don't want regulation they want to and
we're seeing that more now than ever and
they want to be able to to cram more
animals in smaller cages they want to
run
production speeds faster than ever in
fact they're trying to increase the
speed of poultry slaughterhouses now
they're already moving at a rate of you
know every second essentially hanging a
bird and they're trying to double the
line speed so the industry if if there
is no oversight or there is no public
scrutiny would continue to go down this
path that obviously is bad fur for
animals but it's also bad for for
consumers as well and you know we're
seeing more and more of these these
ag-gag type laws that are being proposed
which which really seek to stop the type
of work that upton sinclair did which
led to the first two federal laws
regulating slaughterhouses in our
country and you know these ag-gag laws
which which essentially see are intended
to criminalize whistleblowing they they
want to make it illegal to take a
photograph or a video inside of a
factory farm they are intended to
intimidate people from stepping forward
and really pulling back the curtain and
showing people what where their food
comes from and you know you see the meat
industry in the dairy industry step
forward and put their entire weight
behind bills like this and then fight
tooth and nail against regulations that
would even require animals be able to
turn around in their cages so it's
really clear you know where the
industry's focus is but these ag-gag
laws are are dangerous to democracy as
well it's amazing to me that they
withstand constitutional scrutiny like I
don't understand like I I feel as a
lawyer like I feel like I need to
educate myself a little bit more about
this world because it just does not seem
like it has a place in an open democracy
Tigra wreck these laws that are
preventing consumers from understanding
you know where their food is coming from
is there anything more fundamentally you
know needed from a consumer then to have
an educated understand
of the mechanics behind you know what
they're getting at the supermarket right
you know the the Washington Post tagline
right now is democracy dies in darkness
and that's exactly what the meat
industry is trying to do is keep people
in the dark and so most of these ag-gag
laws started popping up around 2011
about half of the states considered them
most of them were defeated but big AG
states like Iowa who are bowing to the
interest of the agriculture industry not
doing what consumers really want and
consumers in Iowa didn't want an Ag gag
law passed these bills and now a number
of them have been challenged in federal
court as being unconstitutional and a
number of them have been overturned and
the judges have said yes this is a
violation of freedom of speech freedom
of press and in their ruling
specifically compare Mercy for Animals
investigators to Upton Sinclair and they
do say exactly what you said you know
what is more important than a right to
know about where our food comes from so
they're definitely as it is is a
challenge but to me it says a lot about
this industry that instead of seeing the
the issues that animals face and the
fact that consumers oppose what they're
doing which is true I mean you look at
national polls and over 90 percent of
Americans say yes animals including
those raised and killed for food should
not be tortured but then you look at
what's actually happening and these
animals are being tortured so the
industry it has sort of two paths to go
down one is they start to address what
what the animals are enduring or the
other is they just try to stop the
discussion and they want to create to
create a one-sided discussion where only
they can put forward you know these sort
of staged white-glove tour images of
what their facilities look like and they
want to they want to crowd out the
images that are investigators gather
when industry doesn't think that they're
being watched right it would be like if
you went to North Korea yeah you were
guided around that's right and shown the
whitewashed version of what it's like to
be there rice is the reality
what it's really like so you said
something interesting a minute ago that
I didn't want to gloss over which was
that you're seeing more of these laws
come online like so my understanding was
that we're kind of sounding the death
knell for the ag-gag law era but are you
saying that's not the case
well 2011 is when a lot of them came up
there's not more this year than there
had been before and I think that the
industry sort of walked away with a lot
of black eyes and and sort of beaten up
in the press because what AG gag did is
it really attracted a lot of national
media coverage to what was happening in
our food supply and you know what what
are these industries so desperate to
hide most businesses are excited for the
media and for customers to come and see
what they do but it's it's the opposite
in the meat industry and just so we're
clear the way the law deals with
somebody who violates one of these
ag-gag laws is to treat that perpetrator
as a domestic terrorist
yeah and in some situations the penalty
for just snapping a photograph while
someone beats a pig for example carries
a harsher penalty than beating the
animal does mmm right so they go they go
after the documentarian yeah and not
shoot a messenger not the abuse that's
actually been perpetrated and for you I
mean this goes back your first sort of
undercover investigation was like 2001
right yeah yeah so I was 17 when we
started which gave me a bit of some
legal cover because I was still a minor
but you know nowadays we have people
that get hired at these facilities they
work alongside everyone they have high
tech camera equipment that's designed by
the same people that make equipment for
the FBI and CIA but in the early days we
used a tactic known as open rescue which
started in Australia about 30 years ago
and it's a combination of investigations
animal rescue and civil disobedience all
wrapped up into one
so we would send certified letters to
egg farms in the state and we'd say
we're concerned about what's happening
with the animals there we want a tour
will you give us a tour we never
received any responses so we would then
move move forward and we would go in at
night you know ii am dressed in black
with spelunking lights on and we would
essentially go through these unlocked
doors we weren't there to damage
property we were there to document and
to help animals so we would go in
through the manure pits of these huge
factory farms sometimes these manure
pits are seven eight feet high and then
we would climb through broken cage wire
and get to the second floor because egg
farms are two floors high the the manure
is on the ground floor and then the
second floor is where the birds are kept
and we would spend hours at a time in
there documenting with hidden handheld
cameras birds that were impaled by a
caged wire birds that were thrown away
into trash cans while they were still
alive birds with broken bones and we
would take some of them with us to go to
veterinarians to be treated and then to
animal sanctuaries so by doing this work
we were risking literally decades in
prison one one lawyer told us thirty
years that we were facing for doing this
work I would still be in prison right
now yes the first one after you sorted
out the camera equipment I've heard a
couple sort of naive attempts you you do
this exploration you do all this
documentation and you're still 17 right
you have this press conference yeah I
don't get that all this media attention
and you unveil these videos and the
documentation yeah and it causes quite a
stir I mean you're 17 and you're do I
mean that is like ballsy I mean
seriously that takes like a lot of
Kareem I think about what I was doing
when I was 17 you know basically you
know creating creating a media event
around this cause that is not just
important to you but something that you
know all consumers should be aware of
yeah and and actually catalyzing the
appropriate
fact and what I thought was interesting
about that that that story was that the
so the chicken farm is is coming after
you right they're gonna sue you and and
you're gonna be the victim and all of
this but then they realize the media
shitstorm that would ensue from
something like yeah you know to be an
open court would just give you an even
broader platform to speak more you know
vociferously about what was actually
going on and then the whole thing just
goes away
yeah and we did four of these open
rescues so we kept sort of pushing the
envelope as years went on went them
through from 2001 to 2004 and we knew
that we were taking legal risk it wasn't
our preference to go to jail because we
knew you could help more animals outside
of jail than we could behind bars but we
were willing to to take that risk
because people didn't know what was
happening again this is really before
the rise of social media so to get
people to even see a few seconds of what
inside of a factory farm look like we
would need to sort of take some some
pretty you know drastic measures to get
the media national or local media to pay
attention just long enough to put these
images on the local news so you got to
crack the code on marketing yeah in a
pre social network era right interesting
let's talk a little bit about labels I
mean you mentioned earlier there is
growing consumer concern and compassion
around these ideas right and when you
know the average human being or consumer
actually gets a glimpse at what is
actually going on they don't like it
like word know but you know we're
inherently compassionate like yeah
nobody wants this to be happening to the
animals we just sort of accept it and I
think the term you use in your book is
you know there's a there's or I read an
interview somewhere where you are asked
you know why do we allow this to
continue and there's there's a level of
willful ignorance which is so crazy use
and I think that's that's right you know
there
there is it's not that we want it to be
this way it's just that we're either
uneducated
or because we're so disassociated from
the process of where our food comes from
that it's easy to be willfully ignorant
to choose not to watch those videos like
you know oh don't show me that
or like scroll quickly through your
Facebook feed when you know Nathan's
latest video comes on I'm following him
because I want to know but like I don't
really want to you know what I mean like
that kind of thing right and so industry
is aware of this and we live in a
capitalist society and as consumer
habits begin to shift and issues like
wellness and you know humane the humane
treatment of animals becoming more of a
cultural priority we have kind of
stepped into that as a society to deal
with it
not necessarily by redressing the cause
and getting to the root of the matter
but by kind of placating people with
these labels whether it's cage free or
grass-fed and and now there's so many of
them like some of them more worthy than
others but it's almost so confusing now
that because there's like ten labels on
every food product like what does any of
this mean right is this real you know
beyond just the picture of the pasture
on the on the on the thing of eggs that
makes you feel good without any meaning
whatsoever so walk us through like what
these labels are the main ones what they
actually mean the reality versus like
the proposition yeah so there's a lot of
what I call humane washing that's that's
happening you have a lot of people who
as you just said are becoming more aware
of what's happening they know that
factory farming is bad that animals
suffer they don't want to support it now
we believe that Mercy for Animals the
best thing is to move towards a
plant-based diet it's really the
compassionate choice that we can make so
we don't endorse any of these animal
products because there is always
inherent cruelty that goes with it
whenever you're going to make an animal
a commodity and view them as a
production unit
their welfare is always going to be
secondary or further down the line to
the to the bottom line and as you said
the the labels really do vary
dramatically you have some that are
essentially rubber stamping what the
industry is already doing so those are
labels like United egg producers
certified if you see those if you see
that label on an egg carton that means
that those eggs are from a factory farm
and the birds are kept in cages and they
can't spread their wings but it just
means there's an egg in this box that's
right and in the primary trade
association for the egg industry
acknowledges that there's an egg in that
box and I talked a little bit in the
book about how the initial label was
called the animal care certified label
that was also put on egg cartons with
hens that were kept in these battery
cages but mfa another organization said
this is consumer fraud you need to
change this and the Better Business
Bureau got involved in the Federal Trade
Commission and they changed it to now
United egg producers certified then you
have labels like American Humane
certified which is from the American
Humane Association which is also
completely meaningless this is the same
organization that's behind the no
animals harmed and making of this film
labeling that you see on films which has
come-to under scrutiny because they will
put that label on films or animals have
died or been killed or nearly drowned
abused just terrible things so so what's
going on over there what is the purpose
of that organization well it's it is
essentially it has become almost a front
group for animal use industries they the
American Humane Association finds
themselves on the opposite end of animal
welfare issues then pretty much every
other animal organization and bullhooks
is an example of that they actually came
out in support of these sharp metal
weapons that are used to beat elephants
in circuses no other animal protection
organization would do that because it's
not in the best interest of elephants so
you have an organization that has a
really wonderful sounding name that has
essentially
been co-opted to just fall in line with
what animal use industries are doing so
it's incredibly misleading there now
almost like a lobbying group yeah like a
super pet like these super PACs where
they have these names that's right and
great you have no idea what they're
actually exactly exactly and this
American Humane certified label is now
appearing on Butterball turkey foster
farm chicken in we I talk in the book
about an investigation that we did at
foster farm chicken operations here in
California that actually led to criminal
animal cruelty convictions at one of
these American Humane certified
facilities so you have that on one end
and then on the other end you have
things like the whole food program where
there's a tear you know five tear and
you can actually see what the different
labels mean you know one through five
and then in the middle you have cage
free which you know is arguably better
than keeping hens and battery cages but
it's a far cry from what most people
think right like that what is cage free
so cage free means that the birds are
not kept in these individual cages that
we talked about earlier but they're
essentially caged by the bodies of other
animals they're they're kept in the same
oftentimes windowless sheds like broiler
chickens or meat or meat type birds by
the tens of thousands and they don't
have access to the outdoors and there
are there are serious problems
associated with that you have
cannibalism you know birds can only
establish a pecking order with up to
about a hundred other birds that's
that's that's how many birds they can
recognize they can determine you know
who's in charge what the social
hierarchy supposed to be that gets much
larger than that it's chaos and there's
there's no social order and the birds
start to cannibalize and attack each
other so you have a lot of issues at
that with and and then of course you
have the male chicks that are still
killed and the birds are still killed
when their production declines there's
no you know cage free sanctuaries either
and then you have free range which is
essentially what I just described but
the birds should have access to the
outdoor
now the problem is is that there's not
very clear definitions of what that
means so the birds might have a small
amount of access to the outdoors for a
large number of birds and then you have
pasture based and in sort of a varying
degree of freedom that the birds are
supposed to receive but there's not
there's not very strict regulation of
what the terms are or who's overseeing
it
so you know as you can see there's there
are a lot of labels that are aimed at
making people feel good about what
they're buying but oftentimes they're
it's not really clear what they mean and
in what they mean is much less than what
people expect right I think it's super
instructive what you had to say about
the American Humane Association I mean
just seeing that word humane on a label
on a box or packaging any you know the
the average consumer would just be like
oh it's humane it's good you know it's
humane I'm good you know it's crazy
about it's about guilt alleviation right
as much as anything else like as long as
I see that then I have no internal
conflict yeah and you know I I know
people who say oh yeah you know I only I
only eat you know free right animals
that are free ranged and the truth is
that's not true because it's it's very
difficult to you know eat on the go and
eat in all these places and actually
know where any of your food is coming
from like it's under such sort of
limited set of circumstances where you
actually would be able to know where
your food is coming from and that's why
I say even if you don't have a problem
eating animals and and and you're okay
with eating animals if they if they're
raised in a under certain conditions the
truth is that it's just not as practical
to live in line with those values as it
is to eat plant-based it's always you
know it's much easier to eat plant-based
food knowing that you're not supporting
animal cruelty then pretending that
you're only gonna you know eat meat
raised under of animals raised under
certain circumstances because you just
it's just not available to people yeah
it's a very interesting psychological
and philosophical discuss
an argument to have because someone like
Gary Franchione would say that this you
know the sort of grass-fed movement and
this this explosion of at least the idea
if not the reality of humanely raised
meat is actually harming the movement
because it is going to the heart of that
guilt alleviation it makes people less
likely to ultimately abandon meat or go
plant-based because they feel better
about the choices that they're making
yeah I don't believe that that's the
situation that we're in for a number of
reasons one is I think we have to look
at the ethics that are at hand and say
the animals that are unfortunate enough
to be raised into the food system
because like it or not there are people
that are eating meat
most people are eating meat right now
and most people that eat meat aren't
sitting down and thinking about the
lives that these animals lift they're
going to the drive-through they're
getting meat you know this is not in
Canada patty the patty the hamburger
patty tree that's right unfortunately
it's just not on most people's radar
that this isn't like at the front of the
of their mind so the animals that are
being raised and killed in these
conditions I believe it is our moral and
ethical responsibility to ensure that
they are not tortured to do what we can
to alleviate the worst forms of abuse
that they are subjected to and anything
short of that I think is is in line with
species of use to say no we shouldn't
advocate for these animals to live
better lives to me is to say let them
suffer and let them suffer in the worst
way possible and fall in following that
sort of argument you could say well if
it's just about argument sakes
and and people not feeling good about
eating meat then treat animals worse
make sure that all of them are skinned
alive then you can tell people at every
animals skin the liven isn't that
terrible then it will wait on their
shoulders but nobody would say that
hopefully because that's so absurd and
if you look at at countries where
there's a higher rate of vegetarianism
especially like and
in western societies these are also the
places where there are higher animal
welfare standards and higher laws
protecting animals from abuse so I think
when we have laws and policies that move
the ball forward for how farmed animals
are treated it it says these animals
matter we can't just treat them any old
way like we have to acknowledge that
they have feelings and even if you're
gonna use them that they can't be
treated in the worst way possible and I
think that that is a step forward and
ethical evolution in our relationship
with animals it's not it's not the end
game it's not a place where we're having
a completely respectful relationship
with animals by any means but I think
that it does move the middle needle
forward but I think the movement and
certainly Mercy for Animals does this
needs to be clear about what's actually
happening you know and when there there
is a move of getting animals out of
cages we say this is progress but this
is not good enough this isn't the end
game this doesn't mean that that cage
free is cruelty free for example and and
I think that there are some some
organizations that do rubber stamp and
endorse these animal products Mercy for
Animals is not one of them we never
happy we never will be because we don't
need to be eating animals and and
because of that it will always be
unnecessary suffering and unnecessary
violence that these animals are being
subjected to for our food
where are the battle lines currently
being drawn like where is the where is
the war where does it sit right now like
where what needs to be addressed first
and yet are the resources and the energy
and the focus being directed in terms of
of animal welfare campaigns or just the
movement of are also interested in kind
of canvassing the legislative regulatory
landscape of what is actually happening
right now so a lot of the change that
we're seeing in terms of how animals are
treated on farms is happening on the
corporate level and you have companies
like Walmart
that sell a quarter of the groceries in
this country they have more power to
change the fate of animals than most
states do and you have McDonald's you
know buying billions of eggs every year
etc so we've been able to help drive
change through corporate policies we've
gotten over 200 companies to change
their policies to the tune of over 1.2
billion animals that will be affected by
those policies every year it started out
with gestation crates getting pigs out
of gestation crates then it moved to
battery cages and getting hens out of
battery cages and now the the primary
focus for us is the treatment of broiler
chickens so again they are they are like
the 99% of the 99% and only 300 a second
or yeah like that yeah are being killed
right it's astronomical so right now
we're focused on addressing the
slaughter of these birds because they're
killed in a way that would be prohibited
if we even killed cows or pigs in that
way so trying to get it so that these
these birds are not dumped out of shock
wood crates while they're alive snapped
into shackles while they're still alive
using inert gases to put the birds to
sleep so they're never handled and they
never have to endure that that cruelty
changing the genetics of the birds so
that they grow slower and not so so
large giving them access to natural
light so that they can have that you
know the semblance of a day and the
natural energy and the natural um
activities that come along with that
giving them environmental enrichment you
know these are animals with with minds
and curiosities and they should have
things to do with their days so those
are those are some of the the things
that are being pushed forward for for
for chickens the next the next real
battle is for for fish you know they are
raised in much the same way on factory
farms now in some of these fish it takes
them a number of years to reach market
weight what's considered market weight
so the the duration of their self
spring is very long and you know they're
they're kept in these concrete tanks
crowded together you've got poor water
quality you've got mites essentially
parasite infestations that the the fish
suffer from a suffer from blindness then
you have handling the cruelty and the
way in which they're slaughtered so
we're starting to lay the foundation for
doing work for fish probably in the next
year or so on the legislative front I
think it's pretty exciting what's
happening actually in Massachusetts last
year voters overwhelmingly passed an
initiative that would prohibit hens from
being kept in cages pigs in gestation
crates calves and veal crates but what
was most meaningful was that it also
prohibited the sale of products from
animals kept in these restrictive cages
now that initiative is coming to
California and an Lobby kids have
started gathering half a million
signatures to place it on the ballot for
next year which is essentially builds
off of prop two which passed in 2008
with over 63 percent of the vote and it
also prohibits products from being sold
in the state of California from animals
kept in these tiny enclosures so it
should have a you know ripple effect
right that's amazing that's pretty cool
yeah what do you think are the the big
obstacles that you face in terms of
trying to get people to understand where
you're coming from I mean you know we
still have a long ways to go like I said
earlier a lot of progress has been made
and you kind of break it down generally
generationally yeah look like you the
baby boomers 1% of them we're vegan or
vegetarian Gen X 4% millenials 12% so
yeah there's a trend here a huge trend
trend still you know most people not on
board yeah and they say that a tipping
point is 10% so if you look at
millenials you know it's clear that
we're over the tipping point and I'm I
am optimistic at the end of the day and
I say with the work that I do I see the
darkest side of you may
with how people can be cruel but in the
same day I see the brightest side of
humanity I see the kindness creativity
ingenuity you know and encourage that
people can have to make the world better
for themselves and for it for animals
and for our environment so I believe
that that innovation will help save us
front from from these these challenges
and I talk in the book about how the
meat industry is right for disruption
you know it is it's just outdated it's
inefficient to funnel so many grains
through an animal most of it being used
just to keep the animal alive and energy
and then part of it being defecate about
to get a small return essentially so you
know if you look at the transportation
sector you look at what got horses off
of the the busy streets pulling these
you know heavy carriages and enduring
the blistering heat and the the freezing
temperatures yes there was
ethical concern but it was Henry Ford in
the Model T that made writing horses
appear to be just so outdated and
inefficient and silly and the same thing
you know happened and getting and
driving and end too much of the whaling
that was happening it was you know
kerosene and other oils and you know we
look at the changes in how we
communicate and and not sending so much
paper mail because we can get you know a
million times more information on our
phone so there is it and you see what's
happening in the energy space moving you
know towards clean energy and solar and
all of this so the same is happening in
the protean space and I know you talked
about I'm speaking with Bruce from the
good food Institute I talk in the book
about co-founding the good food
Institute because I do believe that
innovation in the protein space has the
potential to just dramatically change
the game some of that in plant-based
proteins but also in clean meat you know
taking a harmless biopsy from an animal
getting a stem cell growing it and a
suitable medium and a bioreactor
Brewery and creating real meat without
outside of the animals and I consider
this as others do the second
domestication the first you know 10,000
years ago the Neolithic period and we
started domesticating animals and plants
that essentially led to agriculture that
led to society as we know it today in
many ways the second domestication being
cells and us and I think it being a
reflection of our ethical growth and our
intellectual growth and our
understanding of science so we can you
know get all the benefit without the
harm and to me that's really exciting
it's crazy times I mean it's literally
science fiction
no no it's amazing what is happening you
know specifically with whom with valetti
and a team at Memphis meets and yet
they're innovating and and the momentum
that they have right now and certainly
there will be I mean this is coming like
this yes this is happening right and
there will be an acclamation curve yeah
in the same way that we're gonna have to
get used to self-driving cars and that
weird that is and it's going to be
sooner probably from it than later yeah
we're gonna have to overcome this weird
icky feeling or sensibility that we have
around eating what is ostensibly animal
flesh without there ever being an animal
yeah that's weird it's weird you don't
let's just say it let's not pretend ya
know that it's normal because it's not
but I think this is the future as crazy
as that sounds and in many ways it's
miraculous it's a little I mean if I'm
being totally honest it's like okay like
is this safe like is this the evolution
of GMOs like what are we really doing
here what is the long-term implications
of human health and I think all of that
hopefully is getting addressed and
studied diligently but presuming that
that gets worked out the idea that we're
going to be engineering animal flesh and
and can kind of a tune it to make make
it healthier then you know the animals
that we're raising with you know less
saturated fat and whatever
and all that as it is that's coming
online and that has the potential to
literally eradicate factory farming as
we exactly exactly and that that's
that's what I'm so excited about is you
you look and as you mentioned uma and
Memphis meets attracting investments
recently from Bill Gates and Richard
Branson though perhaps most excitingly
from Cargill the largest meat companies
in in the u.s. we're realizing that in
order to survive they don't want to be
like the music industry that's right it
passed by like they're gonna have to get
on board with this now or that's gonna
get innovated right out of business
that's right so they see that the
writing is on the wall and you know what
I tell fellow vegans is you don't need
to eat clean meat you know if it's not
something that you're interested in
that's totally fine this is for the
ninety-eight percent of people that that
are looking for for meat and it's it's
it's so good for animals but as we
briefly mentioned you know we are a
really crucial time in in our lives and
humans society and and the health of our
planet with with climate change with you
know racing towards fishless oceans by
by 2048 like all of these think that
being in the middle of this the sixth
mass extinction like things are dire we
have to make some really meaningful
changes and clean me uses fifty percent
less energy it it uses over ninety
percent less land mine percent less
water emits ninety percent less
greenhouse gas emissions you know so
it's it's not only sort of an ethical
Savior perhaps but environmentally as
well and as I said we're gonna have
nearly 10 billion people here by 2050 so
I think we can't just wait for the
entire population to have an ethical
awakening on these issues we need to
have
the the sustainable and ethical choice
be the convenient choice the default
choice you know so when the mother in
Michigan is going through the drive-thru
and she's getting a burger it tastes the
same the price is the same or even
cheaper but it happens to be meat that
is grown through cellular agriculture
instead of animals that are tortured you
know then I think we're starting to get
to a place where real progress is being
made or a super tasty veggie burger or a
super tasty veggie burger yeah 100% it's
a race against time yeah and it's
interesting that you know we really are
running out of time like yeah when you
really look at what's going on
environmentally like we're we are
running out of time and and it's gonna
be down to the wire I think I agree and
and it's interesting that all of this
technology is coming online now almost
like you know necessity is the mother of
invention I think we need it now and now
it's happening can we get it up to speed
in time because how else are we gonna
move forward you know factory farming we
just can't continue down this path and
expect to preserve our planet we've
we've established beyond a shadow of a
doubt the damage that it's doing and as
we escalate towards 10 billion people we
can't continue to do it and look you
know grass-fed beef ain't going to cut
it and you know this idea that we're
gonna re pasteurize you know arid lands
through cat it's just I don't buy it you
know that's not how we're gonna feed the
planet no and like you said we don't
have to wait for clean meat to come to
market we can start eating a plant-based
diet right now so we are the opposite of
helpless in this situation but as you
said it's going to be down to the wire
the what's going to save us or kill us
is the choices that we all make the
choices that we make in our everyday
food choices but also the choices that
we make whether we're going to become
part of the solution or not whether
we're going to find our own unique
voices and skills and talents it and use
our resources in a wave
is moving us towards a humane and
sustainable future or moving us in in an
accelerated path to destruction and I
talk in the book about some really you
know inspiring individuals that had that
aha moment had the lightbulb come on saw
what was happening and instead of saying
someone needs to do something about that
they said I need to do something about
that I realized I am a someone and you
know that's that's what one of my
biggest hopes is from the book and just
from Mercy for Animals work in general
is that people will at the end of the
day be inspired to help drive change and
and there's so many ways in which we can
do that whether that starts out by
changing your own diet whether that's
donating to organizations that are
having an impact or whether that's you
know starting an innovative company I
have friends that are artists that use
their platform to inspire people to
think about what's going on I have
friends that have started vegan bakeries
you know that show people how tasty and
easy it can be I have friends that have
stayed in the business world so that
they can earn to give and they now have
literally dozens of people around the
world that are working full-time on
behalf of animals because of that
decision so the answer to what you can
do I think is a bit different for
everyone but the truth is that we have
to do something and being an advocate
and I think sort of living your values
is the ultimate expression of love
it's the ultimate way of being present
you know there's a quote that says
activism is my rent for living on this
planet and to me that's definitely true
but it's also you're paying double going
bank you might need to have a talk yeah
so it you know to me I it's it's kind of
this this double win you get to make the
world a better place but you also get to
bring so much meaning into your life
we live in a time where there's this
kind of happiness economy and everyone
is trying to figure out how am i HAP how
do I become happy you know and I think a
lot of people realize once they're down
that path that you know a faster car or
a bigger house or you know a nicer
kitchen doesn't quite cut it it's a
matter of living a meaningful life
something that is contributing to the
world in a way that's bigger than just
yourself and for me helping animals who
are really the weakest and most
vulnerable amongst us in our society is
as meaningful of a mission as I could
imagine it's to me really telling how
those in power treat those that are at
their mercy and certainly you know
farmed animals literally have no choice
and they have no voice in our system so
I I think that when we're able to extend
our circle of compassion to include
those that we might know nothing about
or elite relate to the least we benefit
from it they benefit from it and our
entire society benefits from that that's
really beautifully put I love it you
said that and I think that the idea or
placing focus or putting a lens on on
how this journey has girded your life
with meaning mm-hmm is part of the
discussion that doesn't get enough
attention I think you know there's a
perspective that someone like yourself
is a martyr you know that you're
torturing yourself and and and miserable
right because you're putting yourself in
these dire situations for a greater
cause but the truth is very different
from that and I've experienced my
version of that which is when you get
outside yourself and you do align your
actions with your values and you make
your life about something greater than
your personal agenda that you achieve
that elusive goal that you have been
seeking which is to be contented and
fulfilled and purposeful yeah you know
and and and you know it's beautiful to
hear you say that and I think that that
you know it is an environmental cause
and it is an ethical cause and it is the
evolution of civil rights yes it really
is it's the next thing that we need to
start paying attention to we've done a
good job of sort of you know in a serial
way you know working our way through the
various categories of people that have
been treated unfairly and and you know
this is where we need to put our put our
focus on now and you're doing a
beautiful job of that the work you're
doing is not only extraordinary it's
impactful like you are making a huge
difference the book is beautiful
everybody should pick it up Mercy for
Animals available wherever you buy your
books right that's fair and if somebody
wants to learn more about Mercy for
Animals the organization I presume the
best place to do that is to go to the
website but how else can people get
involved yeah you can find us online
Mercy for Animals org you can find us on
all the social media platforms simply at
Mercy for Animals yeah I hope that you
will find us that you will follow us
that you will support us that you will
get the book for yourself and for others
for the holidays no it is I love the
book and I think I think you know we
didn't we didn't get into it perhaps in
as much detail if we have more time but
what I love about the book is the
personalization to it we were talking a
little bit before the podcast you know
it's very it sort of opens with your
story well it's a kind of a dramatic
event and then it segues into your
personal story which I found to be very
compelling and you had said well I don't
really want to really wanted to be out
me it's about the cause I'm like yeah
but your story is actually super
interesting and it allowed me to more
deeply engage with you know the things
that you're passionate about and the
things that you talked about in the book
and and you did a beautiful job with
that and
I think everybody should check it out
and the stories that you tell about the
investigations and and you know the
people that you've worked with is really
quite touching thank you yeah it's um as
I told you it was a vulnerable exponent
will experience to write a book about
yourself there were things in the book
that I hadn't even shared with my
therapist thing for ten years yeah but
it was also really important to me to
share the stories of these undercover
investigators who operate in the shadows
intentionally not having their stories
told so that it can be focused on the
animals it's really the the first book
of its kind that really I think
humanizes who the people are that go
undercover that are driving so much of
this change it is it it is a story based
book and as you know it closes looking
at the future of food and Lumas story
and others who have found their voice in
a way that is redefining the
relationship that we have with food and
with animals and right the - Josh is at
hand Creek and Ethan Brown at beyond
meat and impossible foods and the like
and me Oh cuz you know Yoko's that's
right yeah cool
before we close though can we talk a
little bit about circle V yeah this
weekend it's sold out I know you sold
out second year yes what was the idea
behind kind of creating this event and
what is it all about I mean by the time
I put this podcast up it will have
passed but people but excited about here
that's exactly right
I'm really excited about circle V it is
so it's a food and music event that
celebrates animal rights so it's it's
that the vision is sort of the vegan
Coachella and I believe that that music
and art is a powerful platform to
inspire change and to open people's
hearts and minds to think about the
world and think about others in a way
that maybe oftentimes we don't so the
circle V is
just this fun event that has world-class
artists I mean this year Moby is
headlining waka flocka flame dream car
Rory Reggie Watts and others and then we
have incredible speaker panels which you
will be on so like just world-class
speakers you know packed on these these
panels and then awesome vegan food so
you get something of everything wrapped
up into one and like you said this is a
second year it's growing every year
circle vidcom and hopefully people can
join us in 2018 first circle be it's
it's held here in Los Angeles yeah so
last year I attended and I was on a
panel and I just loved it because as
somebody who I've gone to a lot of veg
fest you know I know the drill a lot of
them are very similar and and they're
great I love all of them and I love the
community I'm not disparaging anybody
like I think it's all amazing but there
was something very different in the tone
and tenor of circle v like it's super
rock and roll yeah
you ain't playing around I know it's not
a veg no it's not it's like it's like
like rock and roll it like it's a
different energy to it that's very
Hollywood yeah not in a glitzy Hollywood
way but like when you like if you live
in Hollywood like oh this is these are
people in hot you know I could sit right
very like it's very cool like I love the
energy in the vibe and all about it so
I'm super excited about it I'm super
excited about it as well yeah cool right
on well like I said keep doing what
you're doing
thank you you as well changing changing
hearts and minds Matt I love your
message and and your work and I wish you
well thanks for talking to me thanks so
much for entering peace